first time in 26 years they waited a
long time yeah
very happy that cleveland that's all
right i
am too with just nine days left in his
presidency donald trump faces becoming
the first
american president in history to be
impeached for a second time today
the house of representatives is expected
to introduce this resolution
it calls on vice president mike pence to
invoke the 25th amendment
to remove donald trump from office house
speaker nancy pelosi says that if the
resolution fails to get unanimous
consent in congress
the house will vote on it tomorrow in an
interview with 60 minutes last night she
lashed out at donald trump for his
rhetoric
that helped fuel last week's capital
assault
is anybody running the executive branch
of the government
who is running the executive sadly the
person who's running executive branch
is a deranged unhinged
dangerous president of the united states
and only a number of days until
we can be protected from him but he has
done something
so serious that there should be
prosecution against him
if vice president pence chooses not to
invoke the 25th amendment pelosi says
the house will
introduce this article of impeachment as
early as wednesday
it charges the president with incitement
of insurrection
related to last week's riots and we're
joined now by democratic congressman
adam schiff of california he is chair of
the house intelligence committee and of
course was one of the house managers
during last year's impeachment trial
congressman good morning to you
i think it was a quieter than usual
weekend if you're in the news business
or politics because the president was
unable to tweet
he has only nine days left now in office
and i gather you don't have the votes in
the senate to actually
convict him and get him out of office so
is the impeachment effort in the house
really kind of a marker for history
no i think it's much more than that and
i don't know where the votes are in the
senate
but i do know where the votes are in the
house and in the house we feel
that this man is a danger every day he
remains in office and that we need to do
our constitutional responsibility to
protect the country
and that means if the president doesn't
resign as he should that's the best
thing for the country but
but then this president has rarely done
what's best for the country
and the vice president doesn't do his
job and invoke the 25th amendment then
we're going to have to do ours
and impeach him and i think we should
move to try the case
and convict him and remove him from
office as soon as possible
and if you go forward with it and you're
not sure about the senate are you
concerned
that the move could tie up or overwhelm
president-elect biden's agenda in those
first hundred days because everyone will
be talking about the trial
well my feeling is if we impeach him
this week that it should be immediately
transmitted to
the senate and we should try the case as
soon as possible mitch mcconnell has
demonstrated when it comes to
jamming supreme court justices through
the congress he can move with great
alacrity when he wants to
and if he chooses not to if he chooses
to delay or if some of those that were
supporting
this challenge to the electors this
baseless challenge object to moving
forward
then it's on them what this president
may do between now and inauguration day
but i don't want that on my conscience
so assuming unless we hear otherwise
that mitch mcconnell would not bring
this to a vote in the senate for the
reasons
uh that you point out do you agree with
representative clyburn's suggestion that
you could hold
the articles in the house for 100 days
or more giving the biden administration
a head start before all this impeachment
stuff comes to the table
well ultimately that will be a decision
our caucus will make
from my point of view we need to move
forward with alacrity uh
and for for me the most important thing
is to remove the danger
uh and that means moving forward with
the trial as soon as possible now once
he's out of office
uh that changes uh the the uh the
situation
but uh nonetheless i think we ought to
press forward with a sense of urgency
as a former prosecutor do you think that
the president could be held criminally
liable by the justice department and
should be for the events on wednesday
january 6th
i think there should definitely be a
criminal investigation and the
justice department should follow the
facts wherever they lead and that
includes when they lead to the president
there is no question that in his actions
in georgia in his actions in inciting
the insurrection
that he has exposed himself to criminal
liability and criminal penalties
but the justice part will have to
research and investigate all the facts
there's a lot we don't know
about what went on in the white house
before that
insurrectionary mob made its way up the
mall towards the capitol
that we need to find out and that the
justice department ought to find out
before making those kind of decisions on
the question of what we
don't know since you raise it uh
representative clyburn
has questioned how the protesters were
able to find his unmarked office
uh nancy pelosi last night on 60 minutes
said that this was a well-planned
well-organized group
and without taking away from the heroism
and the courage of most capitol hill
police
are you concerned or have you seen
evidence that there could be some
element here that is a
inside job for lack of a better term
well i don't want to leap to any
conclusions
but certainly watching the video footage
of what took place we saw capital police
officers act with great bravery and we
saw others
engage in what looked like very
questionable conduct
there needs to be a full investigation
of what went so wrong in terms of
security at the capitol
i know from my part the intelligence
committee will be looking at the
intelligence issues that is
what did we know before about the danger
to the capital
and what uh intelligence uh went missing
or
or what uh what failed in terms of the
intelligence gathering process
and coordination with law enforcement if
you could in our final 30 seconds here
congressman do you feel
confident that the inauguration itself
will be safe
i do you know i think that that there
certainly may be violence but i
have to imagine hope and pray that this
time the capitol police
the national guard will be prepared
we'll understand
the risks but but again this is part of
the reason we need to move with alacrity
on impeachment
there's uh there's certainly a danger
that the president will continue to
incite his followers
to further violent activity aimed at
stopping the peaceful transition of
power all right congressman adam schiff
thank you very much we appreciate it